WILLIAM FISHER: Dramatic
works are almost as close
to the heart of copyright
law as literary works.
The premier example of a dramatic
work is, of course, a play.
As you might expect, you may not
reproduce the script of a play
without the permission of the
owner of the copyright in it.
Nor may you publicly perform the
play without the owner's permission.
This rule is not always honored,
but the rule itself is clear enough.
Choreography is a much more
recent addition to the catalog.
One of the reasons for
its late arrival is
that the particular dances
whose status was considered
in some of the early
litigated cases happened
to offend the judges
making those decisions.
For example, in the Dane case, which was
decided by the New York Supreme Court
in 1963, the work at issue
was a mock strip tease
that the plaintiff
developed and then performed
during an audition
for the musical Gypsy.
The court refused to extend copyright
protection to this routine, reasoning,
quote, "the words dramatic or
dramatico-musical composition
as used in the statute must be held
to include only those representations
and exhibitions which tend at least
to promote the progress of science
and the useful arts.
Where a performance contains nothing of
literary dramatic or musical character
which is calculated to elevate,
cultivate, inform, or improve
the moral or intellectual
natures of the audience,
it does not tend to promote the
progress of science or the useful arts.
Thus, not everything put on stage
can be subject to copyright.
While the plaintiff's performance was no
doubt amusing and entertaining to many,
it does not fall within
the purview of the statute
as a production tending to
promote the progress of science
and the useful arts."
Recall our discussion
in Lecture Number One
of the principle of aesthetic
neutrality, which is commonly
traced in the 1903 Bleistein case.
The passage I just read is
one of the many examples
of judges ignoring that
ostensible principle altogether.
The unfortunate effect
of such cases is that
some famous and deserving choreographers
were left out in the cold.
For example, Agnes de
Mille choreographed
Oklahoma, which was--
and deserved to be--
one of the most popular
musicals of all time.
Her dances-- in particular,
the dream ballet--
contributed importantly
to the plot of the play.
She was paid a modest contract price
by the producers, reportedly $15,000.
However, unlike Rogers
and Hammerstein, who
composed the musical score
for the play, de Mille
received no royalties
when it was produced,
because her choreography, unlike
their musical compositions,
enjoyed no copyright protection.
The gap in the law-- the absence
of protection for choreography--
was filled as part of
a comprehensive 1976
reform, which became
effective the start of 1978.
The result is that today, choreographers
enjoy the same copyright protection
as do playwrights.
Unfortunately, it's not always
clear what constitutes choreography.
What about figure skating
routines, for example?
The statute itself does
not define the term.
The Copyright Office has
developed its own definition,
which is set forth on your screen.
"Choreography is the
composition and arrangement
of dance movements and patterns, usually
intended to be accompanied by music.
As distinct from choreography, pantomime
is the act of imitating or acting
out situations, characters,
or other events.
To be protected by copyright, pantomimes
and choreography need not tell a story
or be presented before an audience."
Courts, when construing
the copyright statute,
are not bound by this
administrative decision.
But they tend to give it weight.
As dance and performance art
continue to evolve in the future,
tricky questions concerning
the scope of this definition
are likely to arise with
increased frequency.
In the United States,
choreographers face one more hurdle
if they are to secure copyright
protection for their works.
They have to capture their
routines in some stable medium.
As you can see from the
language of section 102a,
copyright in the United
States extends only
to works that are, quote, "fixed in
a tangible medium of expression,"
unquote.
This so-called fixation
requirement is peculiar to the US.
Most countries have no such rule.
So what does fixation mean?
The term is defined in Section 101.
"A work is fixed in a tangible medium
when its embodiment in a copy or phono
record by or under the
authority of the author
is sufficiently permanent or stable
to permit it to be perceived,
reproduced, or otherwise
communicated for a period of more
than transitory duration.
A work consisting of sounds, images,
or both that are being transmitted
is fixed for the purposes of this
title if a fixation of the work
is being made simultaneously
with this transmission."
The overwhelming majority
of works for which authors
might seek copyright protection
easily satisfy this standard.
Novelists typically
write their novels down.
Photographers capture their images
in negatives, prints, digital files,
and so forth.
However, on occasion,
potentially copyrightable works
fail to qualify for protection
because their creators neglect
this requirement.
So, for example, if a jazz musician
in a live, unrecorded performance
improvises in an original way on a
classic public domain composition,
that musician will get no copyright
protection in his innovation.
As a matter, this means that
a member of the audience,
after hearing the performance, is
free to perform or record it himself
without fear of copyright liability.
Here's a hypothetical
case that may suggest
the scope of the fixation requirement.
A mandala is a highly-detailed
painting typically made out
of fine-grained colored sand
by Buddhist monks or priests.
Mandalas represent the dwelling
spaces of tantric deities.
Most are elaborate, and
require a long time to create,
but they don't last long.
If they're jostled, they disappear.
More importantly, it's conventional,
after completing a mandala,
to undo it by pouring the sand into
a body of water, often a river.
Among other things, this custom
emphasizes the impermanence
of possessions and the importance
of not being too attached to them.
Traditionally, mandalas
were created and dissolved
in private religious ceremonies.
Recently, however, the Dalai
Lama has encouraged monks
to create them in public, in part
to educate people about the culture.
Some have been created,
briefly, in the United States.
In the unlikely event that
a creator of a mandala
sought copyright protection in it, would
he trip over the fixation requirement?
In other words, would he lose
because this work was not
fixed in a tangible
medium of expression?
Probably not.
A mandala is not fixed
in the ordinary sense,
but it would seem to qualify
under the statutory definition.
Its embodiment in sand is,
quote, "sufficiently stable
to permit it to be
perceived or reproduced
for a period of more than transitory
duration," as is evidenced
by the existence of the
photo in front of you.
Parenthetically, the
monk might trip over
a separate requirement for copyright--
namely, the originality requirement
discussed in Lecture Number One.
The reason is that the mandalas
created by monks typically replicate
traditional designs.
But the fixation requirement
would probably not be a problem.
Returning, then, to the topic at hand.
The primary form of creative
work that with some frequency
does run afoul of the fixation
requirement is choreography.
The reason is that
choreographers commonly
fail to write down their innovations.
In part, this is because it
used to be difficult to do so.
Dance notation has
existed for a long time,
but it's cumbersome and incomplete.
Nowadays, it's easier to
fix a choreographic work.
The standard method is
to videotape a rehearsal.
Nevertheless, some
choreographers still forget this.
In the United States, the result is
that they forfeit copyright protection.
Stepping back from this example.
What underlies the fixation
requirement in general?
There are two standard answers.
But neither is particularly persuasive.
The first answer is that the language
of the constitutional provision that,
in the United States,
underlies copyright law,
limits its scope to, quote, "writings."
An ephemeral work, it is sometimes
said, does not qualify as a writing.
In light of how broadly the term
writing is construed in other contexts--
to incorporate, as we've seen,
software and photos, for example--
this textual argument seems weak.
The second explanation is that
there's an important policy underlying
the requirement of fixation-- namely,
that it serves a evidentiary function.
Supposedly, it forces authors and
artists to write down their works
and the result is to provide judges
and juries who are called upon
to resolve subsequent disputes
good information concerning
what exactly those works contained.
This argument is a branch
of a policy argument
one finds in many fields of the law.
The basic idea is that formalities
have important social functions.
So, for example, the rule
found in many jurisdictions
that a will indicating who gets
your property on your death
must be written down and signed
by two disinterested witnesses
serves to caution people concerning
the importance of what they're
doing when they create wills, channels
their behavior into standard forms that
are more easily implemented, and,
again, provides good evidence concerning
what they intended.
The conventional justification of the
fixation requirement in copyright law
fits easily into this
family of policy arguments.
That conventional
justification is also, however,
vulnerable to the
standard retort-- namely,
that formalities are largely
ineffective if people
are unaware of them, which tends
to happen when people are not,
quote, "repeat players."
If many artists-- and many
choreographers in particular--
are unaware the fixation
requirement, it's
unlikely to have a socially
beneficial disciplining effect.
A further indication that the
fixation requirement is unnecessary
can be gleaned from the fact
that most countries apparently
get along just fine without it.
So that's enough for now on
literary and dramatic works.
We'll turn next to music.